now you're helping in many ways fight
the very guy that you used to be
so
big picture advice
what
given that you were that guy how do we
fight cybercrime today and in the next
five years 10 years 20 years 50 years
what advice do you have to individuals
to companies to
governments of
what and also
to uh
elizabeth
like
the
humans
human beings
that
love that live that are friends with
cyber criminals
there's so many lessons
to really be had
from that
you know to me the the lesson
one of the big lessons to me is is
you can't serve two masters you know if
you're if you're that guy that is
committing crime or
that person that's addicted or you're
you're in love with somebody that's
addicted or
has that they don't love you they love
that addiction that comes first it's
always going to come first so you have
to realize that you have to know when to
uh
you gotta know when to cut somebody off
when to end something
that that knowing that they're not gonna
change until they decide to change
at the same time you got to realize that
the only reason i was able to turn my
life around
is because people took that chance on me
yeah you know that's really the only
reason they believe that there's a good
person in there yeah
if if if malarsky hadn't responded if i
hadn't had my sister my wife these
companies that that initially gave me
that chance my ass would be back in
prison for 20 years i have no doubt
about that at all all right
so you have to realize that um you know
cyber crime
a lot of companies that i talk to they
don't really understand the or
appreciate the uh
that networking aspect
that that trust aspect of how criminals
establish trust with each other how they
work together a lot of companies think
that it's a single player that's out
victimizing them and when you really
break down how cyber crime operates that
you've got a group of individuals that
are working together to hit you but not
only hits you but they share and
exchange information freely you know
companies don't do that you've got
privacy concerns you've got competitive
edge concerns everything else companies
don't share information across the board
like like criminals do criminals do that
you have to appreciate that you have to
understand that that big statistic
that 90 percent of your tax use known
exploits it's not the stuff we don't
know about it's the [ __ ] we do know
about we're not doing anything about it
so the way to defend against cybercrime
is is like there's a lot of low-hanging
fruit that you should fix a lot of that
a lot of that so there's a lot of basic
stuff that's already vulnerabilities
update the system security now that
doesn't take care of solar winds right
or cnap or anything like that it doesn't
but those instances i mean okay that's a
big instance
but i mean it is but in the full
spectrum of especially in the future
uh
because there's more and more companies
are coming online right becoming digital
and that it's just more and more and
more
and those vulnerabilities in terms of
human nature so for social engineering
and the actual outdated systems
all of it and some of it i guess is the
uh i mean you're exceptionally good at
this is educating on the social
engineering side right is educating
people and companies that like they've
got to do that you've got and companies
have to you know i made that point that
they never report to law enforcement
that's companies and individuals you
know i've worked with fortune 50
companies
that will not press charges
instead
they'll have that insider or that
criminal sign an nda they'll pay them
off and we won't mention this [ __ ]
anymore
you have to be you have to press charges
you have to report you have to raise the
awareness of everyone in the group
you have to be it's that it's that idea
and i've talked about that before of
understanding your place
in that cyber crime spectrum the way a
criminal will victimize you
depends on who you are and what you do
as a person and as a business so you
have to understand that design security
around that you know we've got 7 500
security companies out there a whole lot
of them are snake oil salesmen a lot of
them is going to tell you that we're the
one stop solution but you're not you're
not you're a tool
all right and you may have a very good
tool but it's not the only tool that's
needed to protect against the attacks
that are out there and we have we have
to be open and honest about that kind of
stuff
so i guess defending defense is not just
like one tool
it's it's a process of just uh like a
diversity and just constantly educating
uh people absolutely so it's the social
side
it's constantly
because there's so many probably attack
vectors oh is this the software that you
have if you look at it that's that
attack surface you can't plug everything
it's too damn large to plug everything
but you can do the best job you can
possibly do but it takes a variety of
tools to do that all right the idea
and arcos is big about that but the the
idea is to
take the cost of fraud to the fraudsters
so high that they basically try to pick
another target all right that's that's
the idea that you want you want it to be
not worth the criminals time
to hit your company
what about uh white hat hacking so like
um
you know hacking for good
sort of testing systems and then giving
companies the vulnerabilities
as you find i think it's outstanding i
do i think that i think pin testing
white hat stuff is outstanding i truly
do i think that
that you have to
it has to be tempered with what
is reality as well though all right you
know we've got a whole industry of
people who try to sell our fed wallets
that i don't know of many are fit
hackers out there on the criminal side
be honest with you yeah so some of it is
just like a psychological safety blanket
that's not actually
providing any protection by the way you
uh wrote on linkedin uh something about
id me
[Music]
what is it
why is it a problem
i was going down a rabbit hole i was
wondering if you were gonna mention them
you know they lost uh i guess i was
partially responsible for them losing an
86 million dollar contract
what was the contract with the
government the irs government yeah the
irs so what is it so id me is an
identity
okay
backtrack id me as a marketing company
that wants to say they're an identity
verification because i just want to
bring this up to see you get angry
okay
i'll tell you what my issue is yeah my
issue here so yeah it's a company that's
used for authentication by the irs i
guess irs social security administration
va
uh
at one point 23 state unemployment
offices few other services so i guess
the idea is that you would be able to
unlock
your account or get get you know uh
authenticate yourself as a human being
by uh using fake your face or something
like that so private information they've
got a they've got a tiered system with
verification they've got uh you can do
uh
they've got a free system which is
questionable where you submit an id and
it's been shown several bypasses has
been shown and i don't want to talk
about their security horribly bad
because i want to be honest there are
bypasses for a lot of security systems
out there right all right um the the
issue that i have with idme is that
their policies are somewhat questionable
um i don't care if you're a private
company that has those policies in place
but
if you're a government agency
and you as a citizen are entitled to a
benefit or a service of that government
agency
and then the government agency forces
you
to give up your complete identity
profile
to a private company and then that
private company uses that profile for
marketing purposes
to further profit things like that i
have a huge issue with that
i don't care if you're a private company
that does that i just don't think the
citizens need to be forced into doing
that in order to get a benefit or
service that they're entitled to
so that's that's my big issue so that
i mean given how much value how much we
talked about the value of identity
you don't think that should be handed
over lightly no
absolutely not and who would have
thought that brett johnson would ever
become a privacy advocate
but
here i am
i mean it's just
people don't understand or appreciate
the value
of who they are
you know and and certainly you've got a
host of companies id means not the only
one but you've got some of these
companies that say
well we strip out the pii
of the individual we're just using the
biometrics and the sites they're
visiting and things like that that's
identity that is you can still ping that
one unique individual out of all using
that information stripping out the pii
you can still ping who that individual
is
you